[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin in allen einen schönen guten
Abend das Fußball Länderspiel gegen
Frankreich und mehr später bei dir im
Sport Norbert genau einen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir und wir beginnen die
Sendung mit der dramatischen Situation
in Libyen
Flutkatastrophe in einem zerrissenen
Land in Libyen sind durch Unwetter
mindestens 5200 Menschen gestorben
tausende werden noch vermisst
das Leid nach der Pandemie long
kove-patienten sollen mehr Hilfe
bekommen der Gesundheitsminister spricht
von einer Daueraufgabe
und Party für die Weltmeister
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Fans feiern das deutsche basketball
team in Frankfurt am Main
[Musik]
wieder eine Naturkatastrophe wieder
Nordafrika nach heftigem Unwetter ist es
im Bürgerkriegsland Libyen zu massiven
Überschwemmungen gekommen es gibt noch
offiziellen Angaben rund
5.200 Tote und noch über 10.000
vermisste die Katastrophenhilfe dürfte
sich auch deswegen schwierig gestalten
weil in Libyen zwei rivalisierende
Regierungen um die Macht kämpfen das
Land somit politisch und
gesellschaftlich gespalten
die international anerkannte Regierung
in Tripolis die kontrolliert den Westen
eine konkurrenzregierung herrscht im
Osten und dort ist die Lage nach den
Überschwemmungen katastrophal viele Orte
und Städte zwischen Bengasi und Dana
sind von den Wassermassen schwer
getroffen worden besonders in Dana das
zeigt uns jetzt Christoph Esterel
zerstörte die Flutwelle weite Teile der
Stadt
Dana heute Katastrophengebiet quer durch
die Stadt war die Flutwelle gerauscht
hatte ganze Gebäude mitgerissen mitsamt
deren Bewohnern viele wurden ins Meer
gespült erst war der Sturm gekommen der
Regen und dann aus den Bergen die große
Welle möglich weil kurz vorher zwei
Dämme gebrochen waren der erste gut zehn
Kilometer vor der Stadt der zweite nur
ein paar hundert Meter ein Rinnsal wurde
so zur Wasserwand
erster Einschätzung ein Viertel aller
Häuser Weg tausende Menschen tot wie
viel genau Helfer rechnen mit dem
Schlimmsten
unabhängige Quellen haben unsere
Informationen bestätigt wonach die Zahl
der jetzt noch vermissten Personen etwa
bei 10.000 liegt eigentlich müsste jetzt
schnell massive Hilfe her aber dies ist
Libyen ein zerrissenes Land zwei
Regierungen die um die Macht streiten
wer in den schwer getroffenen Städten
was koordinieren darf völlig unklar ein
Stadtrat drängt die Situation ist völlig
außer Kontrolle wir fordern alle
Regierungsvertreter auf zu retten was
noch zu retten ist Regierungen sind
verantwortlich für die lebende Menschen
und das eben nicht nur in Dana weil
beide süßer Schah hat überall braucht es
Suchteams Bulldozer Essen und Zelte für
die Obdachlosen
tatsächlich kommen die ersten
Lieferungen am zentralen Flughafen der
Gegend an vorne weg aus der Türkei aber
schon hier wird's kompliziert die Türkei
ist verbündet mit Liebe ins Regierungen
im Westen und interessiert ihren
Einfluss dort weiter auszubauen
gleichzeitig kündigt der führende
Warlord aus dem Osten ebenfalls Hilfe an
unser Kommando organisiert genau alle
rettungs- und Bergungsmaßnahmen ebenso
wie die Suche nach den Vermissten unter
den Trümmern in den getroffenen Gebieten
Hilfe egal wie egal von wem nur darum
geht's momentan im Krisengebiet noch
könnten vielleicht Menschen gerettet
werden in Dana da wo der Fluss ein
ganzes Wohngebiet ins Meer gerissen hat
suchen Überlebende derzeit mit einfachen
Schlauchbooten das Meer ab um wenigstens
einige Leichen ihre Angehörigen finden
und beerdigen zu können
weniger Flugstunden von Libyen entfernt
suchen Sie in Marokko auch weiter
verzweifelt nach hunderten vermissten
über
2900 Tote hat das Erdbeben dort bislang
gefordert und es dürften noch viele mehr
werden Not und Verzweiflung sind riesig
wie auch die Trauer um Angehörige und
Freunde vielen Betroffenen fehlt es
vielfach auch an Lebensmitteln und
Wasser über die aktuelle Situation
berichtet jetzt Anna Warsberg
das Erdbeben hat ihre Häuser zerstört
unzählige sind nun obdachlos wissen
nicht wie es weitergehen soll erst
einmal bedeutet das Aus harren in
provisorischen Zeltstädten wie hier in
AMS in der Provinz
ich brauche eine bleibe ich muss doch
irgendwo Leben jetzt kommt auch noch
langsam der Regen und wir sind fünf in
der Familie meine Schwiegermutter meine
beiden Kinder und meine Frau
hier gibt es inzwischen immerhin das
Nötigste
Organisationen haben Gott sei Dank
Lebensmittel und Decken gebracht wir
haben genug zu essen die Behörden tun
ihre Arbeit
zu vielen zerstörten Dörfern ist der
Zugang aber weiter erschwert dort wo die
Straßen inzwischen geräumt sind stauen
sich Krankenwagen und LKW mit
Hilfsgütern viele hier fühlen sich im
Stich gelassen
der Start ist nicht gekommen wir haben
niemanden gesehen nach dem Erdbeben kam
sie um die Toten zu zählen seitdem ist
keiner mehr da kein Zivilschutz keine
Hilfstruppen der marokkanische
Regierungschef hat jetzt Entschädigungen
für die Menschen im Erdbebengebiet
versprochen und das Internationale
Komitee vom Roten Kreuz und rotem
Halbmond bitte die internationale
Gemeinschaft um rund 100 Millionen Euro
um die derzeit dringendsten Bedürfnisse
decken zu können nämlich Gesundheit
Wasser Sanitäranlagen und Hygiene
Unterkünfte Hilfsgüter und
Grundbedürfnisse
im Moment sind ausländische
Rettungshelfer Teams aus Spanien
Großbritannien Katar und den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten vor Ort so wie das
Marokko deutschland beteiligt sich
bisher mit Hilfsgütern
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
arbeitet mit marokkanischen Partnern vor
Ort zusammen mit einer Spende können Sie
direkt dort helfen die IBAN lautet.de
65-100 400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Marokko infos auch unter
spenden.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text
Seite 89.0
in Israel berät das Oberste Gericht ab
heute über die umstrittene Justizreform
von Ministerpräsidenten Netanjahu 15
Richter befachten sich mit Petitionen
gegen die beschlossene Gesetzesänderung
kritiker befürchten dass durch die
Reform die Justiz und die
demokratiegeschwächt werden deshalb
demonstrierten gestern abend wieder
zehntausende gegen den geplanten
justizumbau
wir gehen jetzt nach Tel Aviv zu Michael
Beverungen Michael es dauert ja noch bis
zur Entscheidung der Richter aber was
passiert wenn das Oberste Gericht diese
umstrittene Justizreform ausbremsen
sollte
also egal wie die Entscheidung ausfällt
wird sich die momentane Verfassungskrise
wohl in eine veritable Krise des
demokratischen Rechtsstaates auswachsen
denn was die Regierung das Parlament
hier momentan fordern ist nichts anderes
eine als eine partielle Aushebung der
Gewaltenteilung die Regierung fordert
quasi rechtsfreie Räume für sich und das
Parlament für eigenes Handeln für
Gesetze das Oberste Gericht darf nur in
bestimmten Fällen zu entscheiden und das
kann es eigentlich in einem Demokratie
nicht geben das gibt es nur in
Diktaturen das Ganze gipfelte heute in
einem Schlag Abtausch vor Gericht als
die Richterin den Vorsitzende des
Rechtsausschusses von den religiösen
Sozialisten fragte dann könnte das
Parlament ja auch einfach beschließen
dass man den arabischen Israel ist das
Wahlrecht entziehen würde oder
vielleicht nur noch alle zehn Jahren
Wahlen in Israel ansetzen würde und der
Vorsitzende des Rechtsausschuss im
Parlament sagt und lapida nun ja
bestimmte Gruppen könnten nicht einfach
Beschlüsse der gewählten Volksvertreter
annullieren also daran erkennt man das
beide Seiten unversöhnlich einander
gegenüberstehen am Ende könnte das eben
daraus hinauslaufen dass die
Staatsgewalten einander nicht mehr
respektieren und sich nicht mehr
akzeptieren was das bedeutet mag man
sich nicht ausmalen danke für deine
Einschätzung nach Tel Aviv Michael
betroffene fühlen sich oft alleine
gelassen und Ärzte sind häufig
überfordert über long koved ist bislang
jedenfalls noch relativ wenig bekannt
und dabei gehen Studien davon aus dass
sechs bis 15 Prozent der Corona
infizierten vier Wochen nach der akuten
Phase langzeitsymptome entwickeln die
sind dann sehr unterschiedlich viele
leiden unter schwerer Erschöpfung und
Konzentrationsprobleme aber auch
Kurzatmigkeit oder psychische Probleme
können auftreten in Berlin diskutieren
Experten und erkrankte über eine bessere
Versorgung Andrea Maurer dazu
Mia dico leidet unter den Spätfolgen
einer corona-infektion
herzrasenkonzentrationsstörung
Erschöpfung Schwäche mir ist nicht
alleine wir brauchen dringend eine
bessere Versorgung und das nicht erst
morgen oder in einem Jahr sondern heute
die Patienten sind krank teilweise so
wie ich seit drei Jahren teilweise
infizieren sie sich jetzt neu das
Problem wächst es gibt derzeit kein
Medikament dass die Ursachen direkt
bekämpft
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat sich
heute mit Betroffenen Ärzten Vertretern
aus Wirtschaft und Politik beraten und
schlägt einen sogenannten
off-labelgebrauch von Medikamenten vor
also den Einsatz von Arzneimitteln die
eigentlich laut Beipackzettel gegen
andere Krankheiten zugelassen sind
wir haben sehr viele Medikamente wo wir
jetzt wissen dass sie für longkowith
Betroffene wirken sie werden aber in
Deutschland nicht eingesetzt weil sie
dafür keinen auf Labels Charakter
derzeit haben das muss sich ändern eine
Expertengruppe soll nun ein Sortiment an
Medikamenten zusammenstellen auch damit
Krankenkassen die Kosten übernehmen
bislang stehen 40 Millionen Euro für die
Forschung zur Verfügung Lauterbach will
insgesamt 100 Millionen aushandeln
reicht nicht sagen patientenschützer und
fordern einen milliardenschweren
Hilfsfond wir müssen hier mindestens so
viel leisten wie in der Wirtschaft
beispielsweise auch in der Gastronomie
das sind Hunderte von Milliarden Euro
ausgegeben worden dieser lungenform der
würde ja schon mit einer Milliarde gut
Weiterkommen Betroffener wie Mia sind in
ihrer Lebensqualität stark eingeschränkt
viele werden arbeitsunfähig manche
Experten sehen in longkowitschern so
etwas wie eine Volkskrankheit
wie häufig kommt longkow wird vor was
kann man dagegen tun antworten auf diese
und andere Fragen zu longo wird so wie
weitere Infos zum Thema finden Sie in
unserer ZDF heute App
das Europaparlament macht den Weg frei
grünes Licht für schärfere Klimaziele in
der EU bis 2030 müssen erneuerbare
Energien für alle EU-Staaten schneller
als bisher geplant und ausgebaut werden
das Ziel mindestens
42,5% der Energie aus erneuerbaren
Quellen bis Ende des Jahrzehnts deutlich
mehr als bislang Florian neuhahn
berichtet
der zuständige CDU-Abgeordnete macht
noch schnell einen Erinnerungsfoto dann
ist alles durch
Schlussstrich nach fast zwei Jahren
harter Verhandlung Europa beschließt
heute mit großer Mehrheit neue
ehrgeizige Ziele für den Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien wir sind doch als
Politik verpflichtet auch zu liefern und
mit dieser Erneuerbaren
energienrichtlinie liefern wir ein ganz
ganz großen Baustein ist ein guter Tag
für Europas Energiewende heute bisher
sollten 2030 32% des Verbrauchs aus
erneuerbaren Energien stammen jetzt
setzt die EU dieses Ziel deutlich höher
auf
42,5% im Schnitt zum Vergleich nach den
aktuellsten Daten liegt der Anteil
derzeit bei nur 22%
wir müssen alles was geht mobilisieren
und deswegen ist das Ziel die eine Sache
die andere Sache ist wie wir den Ausbau
jetzt auch beschleunigen und auch dafür
haben wir neue Regelungen getroffen ein
Beispiel bis eine Windanlage in
Deutschland genehmigt wird vergehen
aktuell 5 bis 7 Jahre nach den neuen
EU-Regeln darf das in extra
ausgewiesenen Gebieten künftig maximal
18 Monate dauern überall sonst maximal
27 Monate auf Druck unter anderem aus
Frankreich wurde aber auch das Heizen
mit Holz als erneuerbare Energie
eingestuft das könnte die Abholzung
fördern fürchten die Grünen im
Europa-Parlament doch auch sie stimmen
den neuen Vorgaben heute zu jetzt müssen
die Mitgliedstaaten diese neuen Ziele
bis 2030 nur noch erfüllen
erneuerbare Energien längst auch die
Grundlage vieler Geschäftsideen die
besten Unternehmenskonzepte haben auch
in diesem Jahr Chancen auf den Deutschen
Gründerpreis am Abend werden die
Gewinner in Berlin geehrt zu den
Nominierten gehören innovative Startups
die etwa Landwirt mit einer App helfen
wollen stärker nachhaltig zu produzieren
dabei sind aber auch Gründer die sich
mit ihren Ideen schon erfolgreich am
Markt behaupten und alles zum Deutschen
Gründerpreis sehen Sie hier bei uns im
ZDF ab dreiundzwanzig Uhr
gutes Ende nach neun Tagen Ungewissheit
der amerikanische Höhlenforscher Marc
dicke ist wieder an der Oberfläche in
mehr als 1.000 Metern Tiefe hatte er in
der morkerhöhle im Süden der Türkei eine
markenblutung erlitten fast 200 Helfer
organisierten seine medizinische
Versorgung und schließlich auch seine
komplizierte Rettung Jörg Brase
berichtet
die letzten Meter zurück ans Licht dann
hat es mag Dickie endlich geschafft nach
neun Tagen im Dunkeln gerettet Freude
und Erleichterung bei den Helfern bei
Freunden und Familie des US-Amerikaners
und vor allem beim geretteten selbst
es ist unglaublich wieder an der
Oberfläche zu sein ich war länger unten
als gedacht wegen eines unerwarteten
medizinischen Problems es gab einen
Punkt an dem ich dachte das werde ich
nicht überleben die Moschee Höhle im
südtürkischen Taurus Gebirge ist die
dritte tiefste der Türkei höhenforscher
Dicki war mit einem Expeditionsteam
unterwegs als er in über 1.100 Metern
Tiefe plötzlich Magenblutungen bekam und
sich erbrach sofort wurden Helfer und
Blutkonserven nach unten geschickt
wie ihr sehen könnt bin ich auf den
Beinen und ich kann reden aber mein
Bauch ist noch nicht geheilt ich werde
jede Menge Hilfe brauchen um
herauszufinden
und die Hilfe kam unter Leitung der
türkischen Katastrophenhilfe
Organisation Abfahrt reisten rund 190
Helfer aus ganz Europa an die
Bergungsteams mussten harte Arbeit
leisten immer wieder kam die Bergung
das Problem ist dass es immer wieder
sehr enge Stellen gibt die müssen wir
aufspringen um den Patienten nach oben
zu bekommen
teilweise musste der US-Forscher
senkrecht nach oben gezogen werden zum
Glück hatte sich Marc Dickie so weit
erholt dass er die Strapazen überstand
mittlerweile liegt er in einem
Krankenhaus zur Weiterbehandlung es sei
ein verrücktes Abenteuer gewesen meinte
er mit einem glücklichen Ende
der Hans-joachim friedrichs-preis für
Fernsehjournalismus geht in diesem Jahr
an die Leiterin des ARD Studios Moskau
Ruck und den Leiter des ZDF Studios in
Washington Elma tevisen die Jury würde
ich Elmar the Wissen für seine souveräne
Sachkenntnis und den scharfen Blick für
die großen Zusammenhänge für das ZDF
berichtete er unter anderem live über
den Sturm auf das Kapitol die
Auszeichnung wird seit 1995 jährlich in
Erinnerung an den Reporter und Moderator
Hans Joachim Friedrichs verliehen
so jetzt geht es sportlich weiter und
die Helden sind wieder zurückgekehrt die
Basketball Weltmeister heute morgen in
Frankfurt gelandet und man konnte den
Jungs schon ansehen dass sie ordentlich
Party hinter sich hatten ja und die ging
dann auch gleich weiter hunderte Fans
bereiteten dem deutschen Team einen
begeisterten Empfang
das gab es noch nie
[Applaus]
Deutschlands Basketballer feiern die
WM-Titel und Sie bekommen einen Eindruck
von der neuen Korbjäger Begeisterung
es ist ein Erfolg der als Vorbild taugt
für andere Sportarten in Deutschland die
den Anschluss an die Weltspitze verloren
haben Deutschland ist immer noch eine
Sportnation und
auch wenn es vielleicht einen anderen
Ecken irgendwie verloren geht aber ich
glaube das ist tief verankert bei uns
und so ich hoffe dass wir irgendwie
jetzt ein bisschen so einen kleinen
Zahlen sondern gegeben haben dass wir
für Deutschland Weltmeisterschaft geholt
haben das Glas vorher noch nie und wir
haben Geschichte geschrieben ähm mit den
Hammer Typen in der Kabine so ein Pokal
kann aber auch zur Bürde werden im
nächsten Jahr bei Olympia sind die
Weltmeister aus Deutschland jetzt
medienkandidaten
ja weniger Partystimmung dagegen beim
DFB-Team nach der Pleite gegen Japan und
dem Rausschmiss von Trainer Flick heute
Abend in Dortmund der zweite Test gegen
Frankreich mit dem nur für ein Spiel
Coach Rudi Völler
es ist wohl das letzte Mal dass er die
Rolle des Bundestrainers übernimmt
bereits vor 23 Jahren hatte Rudi Völler
den Job des dfb-teamchefs kurzfristig
übernommen und blieb vier Jahre
ausgerechnet heute gegen den
Vize-Weltmeister Frankreich wir Füller
auch mit personellen Veränderung die
Trendwende schaffen
ich würde am liebsten natürlich auch ein
tolles Ergebnis versprechen es geht aber
heutzutage dann auch leider nicht mehr
aber wir werden wir werden alles
reinpauern die die auflaufen und die die
auch später reinkommen die werden alles
dafür geben das ist richtig gut aussieht
nach dem Länderspiel wartet auf Rudi
Völler bereits die nächste Baustelle ein
neuer Bundestrainer bis Oktober
ja in Dortmund da war ja heute vor allem
Einnahme sehr häufig zu hören Julian
nagelsmann
ja aus München ist zu hören dass die
Bayern auf eine Ablöse verzichten wollen
das wird den Klamm DFB freuen und hier
in Dortmund gab es heute ein
Geheimtreffen und zwar weiter weg vom
Team Hotel Präsident Neuendorf und
dfb-vize AG Watzke haben sich getroffen
und hier in Dortmund drängt sich immer
mehr die Frage auf was ist denn
eigentlich wenn der kriselnde BVB
demnächst selbst einen neuen Trainer
braucht dann wäre doch nagelsmann ein
super heißer Kandidat und das wäre schon
eine Konstellation zwischen DFB und BVB
aber okay hat mir vor etwa dreieinhalb
Stunden gesagt es gibt nur eine Vakanz
und zwar eine vacanz auf der
Bundestrainer Position und es gibt
keinen Interessenkonflikt übersetzt
heißt das wenn der DFB nagelsmann will
dann grätscht der BVB auch nicht
dazwischen und seit heute grätscht auch
der FC Bayern finanziell nicht mehr
dazwischen danke für die Infos Boris
Büchner
ja dann sind wir mal gespannt die
Trainerfrage soll ja zeitnah gelöst
werden bin ich auch gespannt vielen Dank
ja wunderschöne spätsommerabende die gab
es zuletzt und jetzt wird es wieder
turbulent Gewitter sind nämlich
unterwegs in Nordrhein-Westfalen dagegen
ist schon los die A2 bei Beckum gesperrt
und auch in Bielefeld saß nicht besser
aus überflutete Straßen und auch voll
gelaufene Keller
ja aktuell gelten Unwetterwarnungen für
Rheinland-Pfalz Nordrhein-Westfalen
Hessen und Bayern und wie sich die
Gewitter weiterentwickeln und was uns
morgen erwartet erfahren Sie gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute schon mal mit
Dunja Hayali heute um 22 Uhr schönen
Dank fürs Interesse und noch einen
schönen Abend für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend kräftige Gewitter vertreiben
jetzt den Spätsommer das ging ja heute
schon los hier im Nordwesten jetzt
brodelt es über Frankreich und es gab
auch schon kräftige Gewitter aus den
Alpen heraus zum Beispiel aber auch über
der Schwäbischen Alb und hier im
Schwarzwald kräftige Wetter kommen jetzt
von Westen heran und sie sehen auch
schon Blitze entlang der Nordseeküste
diese Gewitter ziehen jetzt im Laufe der
Nacht weiter ostwärts werden morgen früh
die Ostseeküste erreichen und morgen
über Tag verlassen Sie uns dann ostwärts
dann geht's noch am längsten Regen und
Gewitter in Süddeutschland machen Sie
sich also heute Nacht auf Unwetter
gefasst auf Gewitter die mit hagelplatz
Regen und Sturmböen verbunden sind das
geht heute Abend im Westen los in der
Nacht erreichen diese Gewitter
Niedersachsen und morgen früh dann
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern von diesen
Gewittern bekommen sie nichts mit hier
im östlichen Sachsen oder auch in
Niederbayern die Temperaturen dazu
sinken auf 18 bis 11 Grad und steigen
morgen auf 18 bis 24 Grad in der Lausitz
werden es 26 Grad morgen wird es dann
von Nordwesten schon langsam
freundlicher und mit Gewittern geht es
dann am Donnerstag und am Freitag
wirklich nur noch in den alten weiter
guten Abend